welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the boys season two is coming
september 4th
with footage revealing a new member of
the seven storm front and the first
three minutes giving us a sense of the
plot of this second season
now the first season was one of my
favorite series of 2019 so i'm gonna
break down all the little horrifying
details that you might have missed
because you know you're probably
covering your eyes but i'm still doing
this because i'm the one on camera right
now and
i can do whatever the i want and if
any of you have complained
i'm laser every one of you okay
let's start with stormfront homelander
and maeve are shooting a promo for the
saving america campaign
to face the supervillain threat i'm
assuming this is referring to the
foreign super villain that we've seen
outside of vots control powers derived
from the a train delivered compound v
but more on that dude in a bit here
homelander and maeve are pulling their
rehearsed shtick
homelander gives a nod to a passing
soldier as he always acknowledges the
real heroes
maeve is still clearly burying her
haunted soul after the flight 37
incident in season one
but stormfront arrives and exposes the
whole promo on instagram live
fyi not a real base as if homelander and
maeve are gonna eat
mres and piss in a ditch with the rest
of the group
also you might recognize army boy as
hotel clerk number two from the devil's
breath
episode of criminal minds beyond borders
now in the comics stormfront leads the
superhero team called payback a parody
of the avengers
he is an early superhero from hitler's
third reich that vocal palm used as an
inspiration for homelander but the show
has gender swapped the character
with aya cash playing an influencer with
less of the direct nazi origin
but still likely embracing some of the
modern white supremacist beliefs
her costume maintains the eagle emblem
that's now moved down to the belt buckle
now stormfront using instagram live
poses a huge threat to vot
and the seven it's allowing an
unfiltered bts look at their
bullshitting
i don't expect mr edgar or definitely
not homelander to let her keep that
phone on her that much longer if you
look down that instagram live comment
feed there are a lot of fun details it's
all very true to the culture of those
feet so maybe reacting a bit too fast to
the conversation they're watching
channel minor
a train for you says hello from
argentina does a
inner a train mean like you're finished
super quickly
maver mauve is my queen 44 asks who dat
redhead
funny joke how most of these users can't
spell made correctly it is hard to spell
that a before e
is awfully confusing there's another
name big game plus size queen
amr okay stormfront cites the devil's
breath episode of criminal minds beyond
borders
which was a real police procedural since
cancelled and that was a real episode of
that show
set at a hotel in bogota about the
devil's breath drug that zombifies its
victims that actor might have been in
that episode
pop clawsicle comments devil's breath
was great vaught rocks my socks 78
comments r.i.p criminal minds bb
too soon okay next hi my nana's your
biggest fan
i'm stormfront great right yeah from
seattle
right uh portland
actually holy your eyes are really
blue up close
yeah stormfront zeroes in on homelanders
blue eyes maybe a little
too obsessed with this aryan features
though after that line my
nana's your biggest fan shade i'm
surprised those blue eyes didn't turn
red
the comments here include stormfront
forever correcting maeve she's from
portland not seattle
and sapiens love the seven commenting
queen
maeve have you ever done keto and this
clip closes with
replacing translucent god bless his soul
who delivered the good news mr
edgar the big guy wonderful
great now of course translucent was the
seven member huey killed early in season
one mr edgar is giancarlo esposito's
character
head of vot and in the comments here
jack off from jupiter posts
r.i.p translucent toronto loves
homelander says stormfront will rule the
seven
maeve beats ww42 comments is
anyone else is lagging ezekiel's spirit
comments on homelander
homie is shook seven nation comments
that smile though
seven false gods writes stan
edgar and never gone
girl comments stormfront will free
america yeah so we're getting a sense of
how stormfront has a devoted following
who might see
homelander as a false god might want her
to take over the seven but how will all
this tie into the plot of season two
well we're gonna move on to the first
three minutes clip that was released
during the recent cast live event but
before i continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every cannonbang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and it has zero calories
get it tastes great
that's a great face there's over 20
different flavors to choose from this
one is a rainbow unicorn have you ever
wondered what a rainbow tastes like or
what a unicorn tastes like i assume
they're the same thing another flavor of
this bang but in addition to the great
taste it's the energy we are talking
about here folks and after a can of
these i start talking faster i get more
done
i feel super but not evil like the
characters in the voice
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bang
energy.com and use the code
newrockstars25 there you can buy cans of
bang energy including their sweet tea
and keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements
all kinds of stuff to be our best bang
self thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25 percent off
at bang thatchenergy.com using the code
newrockstars25
okay the boys at season 2 will deal with
bots in the aftermath of stillwell's
death via homelander with mr edgar now
negotiating with the government matters
like
seven accountability and collateral
damage and he mentions the phrase
yankee white clearance which means the
highest level of security clearance for
personnel working closely
with the president or the vice president
so stillwell's goal last season was to
move the seven into the us military
edgar's goal seems to be moving them
into the highest levels of the us
government
maybe even running homelanders a
presidential candidate or something
sneakier
and easier like getting the president to
select him as a vp
and then making sure that president has
some kind of accident
laser related season one ended with a
reveal that butcher's wife becca is
still alive living and hiding with
homelanders biological son
we think the first natural-born
superhero that we know of made without
compound v
but with homelander now as a family man
politics definitely seem to be in his
future
making a live streamer like stormfront a
real thorn in his side
now the rest of this first three minutes
shows black moore taking out
the foreign superhero with that chess
tattoo a zero dark 30 type mission
insanely gory he slits a woman's throat
so that she bleeds out into the glass
and then he catches that glass and sets
it down because
he doesn't want the shatter to make
noise all of these throat cuts are
stealth motivated
along with this extreme move trigger
warning stuffing a guy's mouth and then
grabbing his jaw and
ripping open his skull ouch but despite
the explosive full body blast black
moore's body can withstand it
revealing to us a new dimension to
blackmoore's abilities now
comic readers know there is more to this
character and despite the adaptation
changes from the comics to the series
i'm thinking the show is going to stay
at least
partially consistent with black noir so
i won't spoil anything if you haven't
read the comics you don't want to know
don't look it up and i ask the
commenters to avoid spoiling anything if
anybody does
please um bury that now we can't
show moses clifford music licensing
reasons
rolling stones charge a pretty penny to
use their music but it's interesting how
black noir reveals his presence to his
victim
right as sympathy for the devil hits the
lyric pleased to meet you
hope you guess my name as if there's
some kind of mystery to this anonymity
and as blackmore totes a dude's severed
head out with him he pauses to darkly
toy with the kid with the stuffed rabbit
with this being the opening scene of the
season i think we can expect mr edgar
his political agenda
and black mard to be the primary plot
threads of season two now of course the
rest of the boys will return butcher
huey kimiko mothers milk frenchie along
with the others from the seven starlight
the deep
a train patton oswalt is joining the
cast in a currently unknown role but
there is some speculation that he will
be the legend
a former vot employee who catches up the
boys on the company's dirty secrets
also show runner eric kripke mentioned
plans to shoot a show within the show
called dawn of the seven
with producer seth rogen starring in it
kind of like the agents the shield of
this universe or
like the american hero story on hbo's
watchman show within show and we also
got the titles for the eight episodes of
the season
check them out now we hope to go even
deeper inside the boys
maybe even look back at that amazing
first season and we will be discussing
an even more on new rockstar's official
discord server which you can join by
becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
follow me on instagram ea boss follow
new rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love
thanks for watching and again let's keep
those comments from getting
diabolical
[Music]
you